[Music]
you
friends welcome to the section on
language so at the very brief outset of
this section let me ask the question
what is language or rather another
question what is it that we are doing
right now now when this lecture is
progressing as I'm talking to you what
we are doing is we are exchanging ideas
and knowledge between them so on and
imparting some knowledge and imparting
some ideas which you are grabbing and so
the medium through which these ideas
that are imparting it emanates from me
and it is received by you is through
language so language basically is a
medium of communication it's it's that
medium or it is that thing which helps
two people talk to each other or two
people to communicate with each other
now look at the title of this slide as
you can see the first part of it is in
English and the second part of it is in
German and so what German say German
part says is and surely come
secondly English which basically means
excuse me can you speak English
a much famous thing or a much famous
word that I used to use when I was
research associate in Berlin and
charitable in what this means is that I
used to often go around talking people
talking to people and asking them
whether they could speak English and so
why I would do that I would do that
because there was some problems in
communication I was not able to put
forward my idea and so this is a forum
or this is basically a way in German to
ask if the next person that you meet
knows English or not without ever
disregarding them in some way so
basically what language is its medium or
it's a channel of passing information
from the sender to a receiver and that
is very important in cognitive
psychology because anything in currently
psychology any cognitive processes any
cognitive function has to have a
language for from through which things
can be communicated and for to start the
lecture I have a slide here as you can
see that the person obviously in the
restaurant he sees a fly in his soup but
then the way he is communicating is he
has mixed up the language and so he says
there is a soup in the fly which makes
no meaning and so communication or
languages although there are a medium of
communication but they have to follow
certain rules and if - if you do not
follow these rules what really happens
is that the whole meaning of the
sentence is lost
so let us then start with the meaning of
language so what is language and how is
it different from communication so
basically is language the only medium of
communication is the language the only
medium of transferring information
between two objects one ascender the
other is a receiver or maybe others are
receiver and if they are then how is
language different from communication
now there are several communication
systems out there in the world for
example microwave communication it
doesn't have a fixed language or the
smoke guns that you see or the honeybee
dance that honeybees do when they find
honey they across certain flowers or
certain sign languages out there and
these mediums are a medium of
communication but they are not language
why they are not language because the
other language has certain fixed rules
or certain fixed characteristics which
most communication mediums do not for
example one rule is that in
communication only brief number of ideas
can be transferred and fixed number of
ideas can be transferred and so new
ideas cannot be generated for example if
the smoke signal says that intruder is
coming that is what it could do but
language on the other hand can be used
can be used to form new signs or new
information that can be transferred and
so the slide is in the the soup is in
the fly or fly is in the soup may mean
two different things the soup is in the
fly which basically means the fly has
drunk in the soup
whereas the fly is in the soup means
that the soup has a fly and so two
different things the fly can have the
soup and so it will mean somewhere in
the stomach assuming that the fly has a
stomach when the other case the soup
being the fly being in the soup has a
different connotation altogether which
basically means that this is non eatable
something which is contaminated and
cannot be eaten so basically then
language is often used as a
communication system but and as I
explained to you there are other
communications or other systems also
there which are not true languages and
we'll see why language is different from
any communication system and so some of
the communication systems out there are
like honey bee dances most from Martin
bird songs and so many other things now
what is the difference between a
communication system and a language a
natural language has to have four
properties first of all it a natural
language is regular which basically
means that it is governed by certain
rules which are called grammar so
certain rules tells the language what
should be interpreted what should not be
rated into what are the anomalies and
how they normally is occur and how it
can be correct also a natural language
is productive which means that it
natural language can produce in finite
combinations a number of communication a
number of ideas so change something into
a language same some part of a language
a new language the new idea is generated
also it is to be a natural language is
arbitrary what does it mean the lack of
a necessary semblance between the word
in a sentence which means basically
means what a word tells and what a
sentence tells or what is the meaning of
a word and what is the meaning of a
sentence are completely different so any
word in a sentence could mean
differently as against what a word would
mean so a bank would mean a bank but I
was standing on the riverbank means
something else so here the meaning of
the bank changes whereas bank could mean
anything in terms of financial
institution or a river bank but when I
put the same bank into sentence like can
I bank on you in this case the idea of a
financial institution is not what is
talked about and so our patroness
basically means that words the meaning
of words and the meaning of sentences
are totally arbitrary and there is no
one-to-one relationship between them
also a natural language should be
discreet the which basically means that
I can take a per sentence and I can
divide it into certain meaningful parts
so that I can study the sentence so
discreteness is a system or it's a
basically property where the sentences
can be divided or the meaningful
sentences can be divided into
recognizable parts so that I can
understand what is the role of a part in
a whole sentence and that is what a
language or any characteristic of a
language should be and this is how it
differs from our communication now what
is the structure of a language any
language what is the structure of it now
languages have a number of system which
works together and evaluating a language
requires the study of conversations
it's basically exchange of ideas between
two people so when two people talk which
we study that we will be able to
understand water language is so
basically conversations are
Brown are out or they are evil they
revolve around listening and perceiving
the sounds of the speaker so it's not
just listening the sound of a speaker or
somebody is saying and recessions also
employ an idea of you should be able to
understand what the speaker is saying so
this is the difference between listening
and understanding now different
languages have different sounds called
the phone names so phone name is
basically a speech sound so each
language has a different kind of a sound
and this basic sound that each language
has for example bar de anza are called
phonemes now the study in which the four
names these basic sounds of a language
for example in Hindi it could be a Hui
kind of a thing which are the vowels in
Hindi thus whereas we call them or Kirk
as wenyan we call them are in English it
is AEIOU which is the verbal or ABCDEF
which is a cdef kind of a consonant in
english so they produce a sound for
example the a sound has two phonemes
into it or two phones into it the a and
the e when we say a it has a and e to it
and so these are the following basic
speed sounds so the study in which the
four named these P stands are combined
in any given language is called the
phonology so basically conversation is
listening to and perceiving what other
people say and that can be done by
identifying the basic speech sounds the
basic phones that each language has and
these phones are the primary phones or
the primary sounds which the language
has and as I explained to you in the
English language for example the word a
has the a plus e sound right and so
these are the two sounds that are sound
the e sound so a as you say now the
various phonemes are these basic sounds
of a and E are combined together to you
to yell a meaningful unit of a language
which is called a morphology so the a
and E then combined together to form a a
which then combines with some other
sounds for example
eighty E which is eight or Appl e which
is Apple and this is called morphology
so fond of the combined together two
usual meaningful words which are
basically called the morphemes so these
markings are generally not word but part
of a word right so for example morphemes
are things like word endings example
making plurals so if I Appl E and if I
add a F s this S which is add to Apple
to make it a plural is called a morpheme
similarly prefixes pencils markers for
example tense markers like for present
continuous tense I used markers like ing
or for past continuous I use tense
markers like heed he walked he is
walking he he will be walking kind of a
thing or he walked so when I say the eet
be to walk it gets convert into a past
tense and so basically these are the
markets now some of the more famous the
smallest meaningful units for language
are words that need to be identified in
order to study the role behind each
words in a sentence so basically then
think of it in this way each
conversation a language starts with
identifying the basic speech sound which
is called the phonemes and these
phonemes are basic phones as I said a
has two phonemes a and E these phones
combined together to form a meaningful
unit for example a morpheme a Martian is
basically combination of phones which
has some meaning for example EB in terms
of the word ending or ing in terms of
coordinating or things like prefixes for
example any any prefix so fulfill
unfulfilled kind of a thing so unhear or
in here kind of prefixes which turns the
change the meaning of a sentence these
are called morphemes and these morphemes
are then governed by certain rule or
governed by certain structure which is
called a syntax so basically the
structure of a language is in terms of
the basic speech sounds which is called
the phonemes at
another level with the phonemes combined
together is another level which is
called a morpheme which is collection of
phonemes but which has some meanings or
which has some meaningful unit of a
sentence
now these morphemes could be anything in
terms of or endings in terms of sentence
markers in terms of critical parts of a
sentence and so on so forth and these
morphemes are then guided by certain
structure which is called the syntax so
syntax is basically the structure of a
sentence now a syntactically correct
sentence does not itself is always good
conversation so basically saying that
all the objects or all the markings are
all correct phonemes or if it has a
sentence if a sentence has the right
structure or the right syntax it may
make meaning it may not make meaning for
example look at the first sentence that
we saw the soup is in the flight know
probably or not probably basically this
sentence has the right syntax is
everything correct in terms of the
object the subject the world everything
is in line but it makes no meaning
because the soup cannot be in the flight
in terms of the context although soup
isn't the fly basically means that the
flag has drank in the soup but looking
at a restaurant scenario where you see a
person taking a soup and then there is a
bowel in the bowel there is a there is a
fly which is on to it
something's basically proves wrong so
looking at the context the sentence is
wrong and that is what I'm trying to
tell here there's every syntactically
correct correct sentence may not be
right now the sentence must mean
something to the listener and in this in
the first case the sentence was not
meaning anything
and so this meaning which is generated
by a sentence of syntactically or offer
grammatically I'm sorry not dramatically
in terms of structurally correct
sentence is called the semantics so
semantics is the study of meaning of a
sentence when you correct so basically
then in a sentence you have the phones
which are the basic speech sounds take
these phones combined together you will
found on the morphine's
which are small critical units of a
sentence for example it could avoid
ending it could be tense markers it
anything and these markings then
combined together in a certain specific
form to form the level of the word and
these words are then governed by certain
rules which is called the syntax now
syntax is how should you write the
sentence but then the syntactically
correct sentence in terms of rules if a
sentence is correct it may have a
meaning or it may not have a meaning and
so this idea whether the sentence has a
meaning or not meaning is called the
study of semantics so look at this here
there is a sentence that I have used and
I will show you the basic parts of it so
the sentence here is the stranger talked
to the place and so let's break this
Indians into its parts so the first
level from the sentence down is the
phrase level in the phase level you can
see there are two phrases into it we
have the noun phrase and the word phrase
the word phase is the phase what is a
phase a phrase is a collection of words
in a sentence which makes complete
meaning right for example if I say The
Strangers it has some meaning into it
and so it doesn't need anything beside
it also I say talk to the place so
although there is a question who talked
to the place but just by itself talk to
the players has certain meaning and some
phrases or parts of a sentence or how
many have a sentence which has complete
meaning and so there's the level of the
strength there the phrase I have an
entree zina were placed at the level of
the word then again breaking this
sentence I have two words the and
strangers and then at the level of the
word on this side on the noun phrase I
have talked to the place for words to
look at similarly at the level of the
morpheme I have the strange and ER s
because strange is the word root word
and ER s makes a number of words so
strangers and similarly here talk is the
word which is the core word and Edie is
the marker sentence marker top so it is
past continent bastions and similarly in
to the play ER NS players which means
the plural of it and then coming to the
level of the phoneme so this is the
level of the phoneme how the is stranger
is spelled here an S is spelled and so
on and so forth so basic base
and structure of any language is starts
with phoneme goes to morpheme which is
combination of phonemes then it goes to
the level of the word where morphemes
combined together to form words which
are meaningful units and these words are
then converted into are mixed up using
some syntax using language rules to make
phrases and these phrases then form the
sentence and the sentence then is looked
for or is thought of in terms of meaning
which is called the semantics now for
conversations to work there must be some
flow so any conversation which which
happens between two people for any
conversation to happen there should be a
flow between the movement of the
sentence so listeners must not only its
listeners the first of a language or
listeners of a particular conversation
should not only pay attention and make
certain assumptions the speaker must
also craft their contribution in what
the ways in which the listeners which
makes the job of the listener feasible
for example think of this sentence so
somebody says I want to read watch in
the other person says the ACS the NASA
is sending a rocket now in this way what
is happening is the two people are
talking together and so one person has
the meaning it's not making any meaning
although two people are making sentences
conversations but these conversations
are not being interpreted and so for
conversation to work listeners must pay
attention not only pay attention to what
is being said but the speaker of a
sentence should make sure that whatever
he is saying should be crafted or should
be made in such a way that the listener
understands it if you say an
incomprehensible sentence the stranger
may not understand the listener may not
understand it and so conversation is a
two-part game where there is a speaker
and where there is a listener so the
speaker should pay attention this the
listeners to pay attention the speaker
should make sentences in a way which is
comprehensible and that's how
conversation flows now the aspect of a
language this aspect of language which
basically decides what a speaker should
say and how a listener should look into
it is called the pragmatics
so although meaningful sentences
although semantics is the meaning of a
sentence but just having meaning a
sentences does not itself make a
conversation so for a conversation to
flow you should have something called
pragmatics into it
which basically is that how
conversations or how things are shared
between people what is it how is a
listener listening to something and what
is being transmitted by the center so
present the pragmatics is the flow of
conversation the kind of flow of
conversation between a speaker and a
listener the idea of how conversation
should happen how a good conversation
should happen is what is called the
pragmatics beside this there is
something called grammar which are sets
of rules for a language now grammar has
nothing to do with the rules of a good
grab good language for example if I say
the word no I ain't coming now if I say
I mean coming in is not a very good work
to look at and the word should be
actually I am NOT coming
but then grammar only points out legal
sentences it only looks for Digger
sentences and it's it's a rule of the
game rule of a conversation but it never
looks at or it never tells you whether a
sentence is good English or good Hindi
or a good language right so grammar will
tell you whether a sentence is following
a certain rule or not or does it is it
correct in terms of rules in terms of
sentence construction whether the
transferrin sentence construction rules
are following in a comprehension or in a
conversation but will not tell you tell
you whether this is the correct way to
speak so grammar doesn't do that and
that's what grammars are all about no
psychologists and psycho linguist the
distinguish between something called
explicit and implicit knowledge of
linguistic rule the idea is how do
people know rules of grammar
how do people what is the way in which
people know the rules of grammar or how
does it grab these rules is it explicit
are we do we know when we look at a
sentence that we are following certain
rules
the glamour of it so grammatical rules
how do they work are the explicit or
implicit in nature so although most of
us cannot state with accuracy the rules
of English syntax but we can basically
find out ambiguities and sentences so if
there is a violation or gamma we can
find into it for example look at the
sentence I ran the dog Street down cat
after you load the welder what does it
really mean it doesn't mean anything and
so if you give them give somebody who
has studied the English language he'll
find out that this is a problem there is
a problem with something in the sentence
and then if you ask them to correct this
is probably what they're going to write
back so people already know no the
explicit rules if you ask somebody who
knows English are studied a little bit
of English they will immediately say
that this sentence is wrong is somehow
wrong it is not grammatically correct
ask them the grammar rule they are not
able to do it but ask them to transform
this and this is the transformation that
most people are going to do they say
that the dog ran down the street after
the very yellow cat and this is the
exact interpretation right so
grammatically this is incorrect but most
people are able to correct it all that
they don't know how this drama really
comes in and so people's knowledge about
grammar is mostly implicit
so our knowledge of rules of grammar is
therefore not explicit we often use
something called prescriptive rules
example what people say should follow so
when we're using or when we talk or when
we use language we generally use
something called prescriptive rules
which tells us how we should talk or
write there are certain prescriptive
rules there are certain rules which goes
around the world which people share
between us and saying how you should
talk and how you shouldn't for example
if you are saying I ain't I am what you
are doing this kind of sentences are not
permitted or not entertained and so this
is the prescriptive rule now in contrast
the articulation of descriptive rule
characteristics of a sentence are very
hard so what people tend to do is they
know prescriptive rules of using
when they when they are conversing they
know what is wrong and what is right but
they don't know what is it in the
grammatical way what is wrong or what is
that and so as I said as I showed to you
that if these two sentences are shown to
people people will be immediately able
to tell you that the first sentence is
something somewhere wrong and the second
sentence is right this is the right
format of it but they won't be able to
tell you where the problem is or what
the grammatical problem is and so
looking at in terms of grammatical is
called the descriptive rule and
prescriptive how they can do it or how
they are able to tell there is a problem
is because they use something called
prescriptive rules of how a language
should be studied or our language should
follow so basically then this is how the
structure of a language is it starts
with something called phonemes goes up
to something called morphemes then there
is the level of the word then there is
from the word there is something called
the syntax which is the meaning of a
language which is the structure of a
language from the syntax there is a
meaning generated which is studied
through something called semantics and
semantics is basically the meaning of a
language but even if a language or even
if a sentence has meaning it may not be
the best way to communicate and so ways
of communication is called pragmatics
and from this pragmatics the certain
grammar follows us how the language is
looked or made undo now let's look at
one by one these structures so the first
structure that we discuss is called the
phones or the phonology now if you look
at German and if you look at French and
if you look at English you will see that
most of them are different languages why
German is a very hard language for
example somebody speaking German will
show I'll sure I'm shooting them or
something like very in a very miss rein
of readers in which are very strong
Germans are known to be very strong
language if you look at French which is
more of a subtle language more of a
likeable language people will be
speaking in terms
some soft languages for example wait we
are some other some other way of in
which I don't know French French but
it's a very soft language look at
English it's more easier so hello hi
kind of a thing so these the languages
hawaii's German a hard language or a
very strong language and French a very
soft language or herbivore for example
is a word in French which basically
means that goodbye
so or laughs ma laughing me for people
for men and women so it's soft in nature
and English is just gentle so how does
this differences arise the differences
arises because the speech sound the
ideal syncretic speech something these
languages are different the basic sounds
are very different and so fanatics is
basically the study of speech sounds and
how they are produced and phonology is
the state of stretch the systematic ways
of integrating these speech sounds and
how altering this speech sounds for
converting the language so basically
phonology is the study of speech sounds
of different languages and these speech
sounds of how they're combined together
how they are altered how they're spoken
basically defines how a language is
treated whether is a soft language hard
language and so on and so forth now for
the English language there are 40
phonetic signals there are four
different take signals which are there
and these phonetic segments are all the
phonemes so what are phonemes these
phonemes are at the speed song as we
discussed in and the beginning of this
chapter the idea of phonetic languages
is in terms of phoneme systems of the
phones which is the basic speech zone so
phones are the basic smallest unit of a
sound let make a meaningful difference
for example ah II the visa
sounds the Czech ones now in a given
language now in one phone a phoneme of a
word is exchanged for another and so
I'll show you that how important they
are because if I replace one phoneme
with the other phoneme in a sentence
then it could it would mean differently
and so here is an example if I replace
the D for name D funning with the T
in a language then that leads to the
duck becoming that back right and so you
see the difference so if I replace one
phoneme one speech sound or one basic
sound in English language the D is
replaced by a T the duck becomes a tuck
and so duck has a meaning duck doesn't
has all the top has a meaning in some
way but then it's not the same thing and
so these differences can arise and B and
P are more or less nearby and they
create something called semantics or
they create something called a caustic
confusion we have seen a caustic
confusion has one reason of encoding in
semantic memory and so this is what
happens so this is a list of IP a list
of different phonemes and so you can go
to these so these are the number of
vowels which are there and these are
number of consonants which are there and
these are the phonemes for it so if you
look into the waffle these are the
phonons for it this is the number of
consonants and these other ponies for it
and this is how the example is for
example there are a as in cat the a as
in arm the a in in a way and so on and
so forth now the psychologists or psycho
linguist they distinguish between a
consonant and a vowel what is the
difference between a consonant in the
world now the English language in terms
of the phonemes they have something
called a consonant and they have
something called a bubble now what is
the difference between a consonant and a
vowel no vowels generally they work
without obstructing the airflow so when
you produce a vowel the airflow is not
obstructed in any way and simply
depending on the shape the position of
the tongue of Ovilus is is produced so
there is no obstruction of the airflow
for example when you say a e i o u it is
the change on the mouth the change of
the s' on the lips which is basically
producing the sound and there is no
obstruction of the airflow whereas in a
consonants the consonants are phonemes
which are made by closing at least one
part of the mouth they different
so basically consonants require
obstruction of airflow and vowels does
not require obstruction or flow for
example when we say
we see k-t all of them require that
their which is pulling from the diagram
up then which is coming from the diagram
up it is blocked in some way in the
mouth and this is what is the consonant
is now the way a consonant is looked at
the kind of obstruction of the airflow
which is generated for producing a
consonant can happen at four places now
or it depends on four factors first the
a place of articulation where is the
obstruction so where is the obstruction
of the airflow occurring for example B
and P sound appears by closing the lips
try saying me with open letter is not
possible so we that's happens so when we
save me or P it happens where
obstructing the airflow by closing the
lips
similarly the s and the Z sound made by
placing the tongue against the hard
palate so say s without pushing the your
tongue towards the upper part of the
hard palate towards this part of the
mouth of this part of the Mott say s3s
without putting your tongue here not
happening
the not happening and so this is what it
is and so putting the tongue or putting
the your tongue at the roof of the of
the mouth of the hard palate is how the
snz sounds are produced the other way or
the other factor is the manner of
articulation what is the mechanism for
obstructing the airflow for example the
word M sounds by closing the mouth while
opening the nasal cavity so say m and
don't close the Masri M not happening or
try not using the result cavity now not
happening so that is the problem here
similarly the sound obstruction of the
air for producing hissing sound so for
example F F is produced F is produced by
this hissing sound or this this
mechanism of our flow airflow or the
mechanism of the hissing the after sound
which is there it produces the F the
third factor which differentiates a
consonant or which happen which makes it
possible for a consonant to occur is
called the voicing so what is voicing
voicing is vibration of the vocal
how does the vibration of the vocal
chord happens now example the word s
doesn't require the vocal cord to or
touch a vocal cord and look into it if I
say s there is no vibration
but if I say Z there is a vibration out
there and so these vibration of the
vocal cord are also the ways of
producing a particular vowel and so
these are the ways in which a vowel
consonant is produced and I said the
basic differences in vowels there is no
obstruction of airflow whereas in a
consonant there is obstruction of our
flow whether it is the level of the
mechanism of our flow or the type of
smart movement which makes their flow or
the kind of vibration of the vocal cord
and as you see this is basically the mod
positions for producing the vowel and
consonant anything else it's a funny
thing yeah so to to show how ovals and
consonants are different now features of
phonemes are involved in certain
phonological rules are governed the ways
in which phonemes are combined and so
these ways in which these phonemes are
combined they give rise to certain
foreign illogical rules now there are -
there are some rules which are followed
in English language for example if two
true consonants are in the beginning of
an English language if an English
language or if a word in an english
language starts with two true consonants
in the first must be an S and this is
one rule which is out there and this
rule makes the top or Mukesh not
possible right and so if we have two
consonants B and K in in terms of the
start of
sentence or starter forward in the
English language the first the rule says
that true true consonants first has to
be an S and that is how it is and that
is why you don't make the top but you
make stop or makes-- or skis as being
the legal words now these combinations
are phonological rules of how phones are
there it gives to certain rules and one
of the rule is the use of the to
concentrate rule and that that is this
is how to pronounce or pronounce
approval happens in English also so
basically these phones these phonetic
rules also tell you how pronunciation of
rules happens in English language for
example if a word ends with the Z the S
the Z the C or s or J or Z then the
puerile are always in the pen in the
terms of a Z for example place the
pluralist places porch its porches right
but if the word ending is in terms of P
TK and F the plural is always in terms
of and s and so these are certain rules
which have been given there are certain
rules which are out there which says how
these spawns that we talked about or how
this world wobbles and consonant that we
talked about how they are allowed to mix
together and follower or a make up a
morpheme or make up a word right so if
we have this PT k the ending is always Z
in terms of s for example lip will not
have libs it will have lips as an ending
because it is ending in a P or if it in
terms are telegraph it is ending in a T
the plural is always in terms of a
Telegraph's but if anything else beside
these number which I have shown here the
plural will always be in terms of said
so basically these are the special ones
which are there so that will give to an
S ending other than that you would have
the Z ending for example club it will be
clubs heard heard kind of a thing so why
are different language sounds are
different why are different languages
they sound different to us first they
contain different
sounds or different phonemes as a German
has different for name example in German
you have ghee or ABCDE
said a gay kind of a thing or you have
things like we and fear the Fatah C&W is
is what is looked into and so different
sounds out there similarly you have
French Spanish and they each one of them
has a different sound and so they appear
differently they have different rules of
combining these sounds for example
fatter and whattcha whattcha and fatter
in in German so we is pronounces V in in
this case and so this is pronounced s F
so when we say Father
they put fatter into how it is or
Schwester and in this sense for sister
so basically different sounds are there
and so this different sounds and this
combination of different sounds are the
two reasons why a german sounds
different from the english language
right so different folds and different
ways of combining or any language for
example it could be french it could be
Spanish it could be Chinese Mandarin any
language you look into there are certain
rules of combining these there are set
first of all there are certain speech
sounds and the certain ways or rules of
command in the speech zones which make
them which makes two languages different
the next interesting thing to look into
or the next part of a sentence or next
part of a language is syntax so what is
syntax it's an arrangement of words
within a sentence how words are arranged
into a particular sentence or the
structure of a sentence now what the
syntax do it tells you the ways in which
different words or larger phrase can be
combined to from leaguers and tenses in
a language for example what syntax does
it tells you how word should be arranged
in in a sentence and what is the
arrangement of words and then it tells
you what is legal and what is not what
arrangement produces legal sentences
arrangement doesn't produce legal
arrangement and for example the SVO
subject/object were kind of a thing
subject word object and sorry SVO format
or the subject-verb-object time format
which basically tells you what should
come before that so our subject should
be always followed by your work in
English and then an object right and so
in English Islam is going to the
villages okay but in Hindi rata hey or
theorem is also correct and so I can
make these transpositions I can make
this movement but then this is this
allowance of movements in terms of
German also that this allowance of
movements is there for certain parts of
the sentence can move but in terms of
village goes to ROM is not correct why
because this movement is not allowed and
though this movement or this kind of
changes is what's in taxes in texts are
rules
which says what in which way the words
could be combined to form meaningful
sentences now to explain what are the
structure of a sentence mean consider
the following for example look at this
intense the top change the squirrel in
the path now if I look into it it is in
the correct sentence interest meanings
now if I break this sentence this is the
level of the sentence and the level of
sentence if I break it it has two
different parts North could refer to the
first figure which I showed you it has
something called a noun phrase and a
verb phrase and within the non phrase
then you have certain other structures
which are there there is something
called a determinant and there is
something called a first noun and though
is called the determinant which is
determining the noun which is the dog so
the dog which dog that particular dog if
I just say dog then it is not referring
to it the determinant is there and so
dog could be anything but then I say
third out chase the squirrel which means
that I am referring to a particular dog
similarly in the word phrase I have then
a different arrangement altogether I
have the word which connects so it is
SVO format as you look into it this is
the subject this is the verb and this is
the object which is then so object a
certain data - into it we'll come back
to that in a minute
then this is my subject this is my work
so what does the dog do the word dog
chases it is chasing down that is the
action that this particular verb is
doing and then I have another thing
which is called the object here so the
squirrel nos Y determinant here the
determinant is because it is squaring it
is chasing a particular square now doc
choose the squirrel which means the dog
just can chase any square but if I am
looking referring to a particular dog
referring to a particular squirrel then
I have to go in with the Data Miner for
it and so the dog chases the squirrel
this could be a sentence but senses in
this sentence has more parts of it it
has something called this part which is
the noun phrase here the part where does
it change the square it changes the
square in the park and so this is a
advanced combination here or it's
another part of the sentence and so this
is this particular thing of breaking a
sentence into its parts of the non
present work phrase and within the noun
phrase for how the verb and the noun
acts in into or how they are divided
into is what is called the the semantics
I'm sorry the syntax now the diagram
shows a label diagram tree and depicts
what is called the categorical
constituents of a sentence so syntax is
basically what words are combined in how
they are combined and so this basically
what we saw is how our syntax actually
looks into now these changes explain why
certain changes are though this kind of
categorical arrangement explains why
certain and certain movements of
sentences are allowable and certain
movements are not allowable and this
taking certain part of a sentence for
example and this part of the cell for
example I can very well take this and
put it here and make this change from
here to here so this the squirrel chases
the dog in the park is perfectly correct
syntactical sentence although it has the
wrong semantics in terms of meaning it
is wrong but perfectly okay so I can I
can take a non phrase and move it along
along this structure along this
constraint structure and that is called
proposing so that is what with which so
this category is a caracal arrangement
this is a tactical arrangement of
Constituent arrangement basically helps
you in proposing taking certain parts of
a sentence and moving it in front of the
others and that it also tells why I
make the square I'll move from here or
the part move from here but I cannot
take the chaise and move it into the
front of a sentence so what can be moved
and what cannot be moved or how can
changes for example I can very well see
that the park chases the squirrel in the
dog right and as perfectly legal in
terms of the syntax but in semantics it
has no meaning at all and so this is
what is allowed and this is not what is
a lot because syntax threw in the exact
meaning and so this constraint structure
this tree structure then tells me what
can be moved and what vendor cannot be
and this movement of part of a sentence
toward the front or back of a sentence
is called proposing for example look at
the two sentences so my naughty dog I am
mad at is not legal whereas naughty dog
I am mad at my is not legal so my
naughty dog I am mad at is perfectly
legal but if I try to propose something
out of here what I want to take this and
put it here then it is not legal at all
similarly that inflated price I will not
pay is perfectly legal but if I try to
prop propose something for example you
try to propose price price I will not
pay that inflated is not legal the
inflated price I'll not pay is perfectly
legal and so this kind of constraint
structure or tree structure tells you or
tells someone using a language of what
is possible and what is not possible now
how do we concisely summarize what can
and what can't be legal
proposed structure or what can be the
way of making a legal sentence and so
one of the ways is that one of the rule
is that only whole phrases can be moved
you cannot move part of the sentences or
part of a particular sentence from one
position to another also there is
something called a phase structure rule
which says that or rewrite describes the
way in which certain symbols can be
rewritten so what happens here is that
it says that certain side symbols can be
related in a certain way and so if it
moves something with it or certain I can
rewrite a particular symbol into some
other symbol and that way I can make the
preposition I can make the
movement similarly there is something
called a transformation rule which says
that structure such as those depicted in
tree diagrams on to other structure
example proposing and so this rule says
that some structures can be moved and
some structures cannot be and what can
be transform what cannot be transform so
there are certain rules out there for
example one rule is that the only whole
phrases can be moved and then the other
is a face structure rule we says that
certain structures in a sentence can
again be rewritten or broken down into
other structures and that decides what
can good or not and there is a
transformation rule which says that what
can be moved in what cannot be moved and
that says how sentence can make meaning
or how can a legal sentence be formed
and so as you look into it mr. Park II
had a problem with his sentence and that
can create problems for example it says
work for will work as food not as food
will basically mean that he'll be eaten
up right and so there is a problem he
says will work for food could be the
right thing now the next part of what we
look into is called the semantics so we
looked at syntax in the rule of it and
semantics is making meaning so semantics
is basically the study of meaning and
plays an important role in language any
any language a meaning has to be there
if the meaning is not there then there
is a problem so although there is no
complete theory of meaning as as of now
and there are there is attempt to make a
universal theory of meaning which color
which captures everything but then
births which in 1970 he says that any
theory of meaning should have or should
be able to explain several things at a
minimum so any theory of meaning any
semantic rule should be able to explain
certain kind of deviations or certain
kind of factors which is there first of
all any theory of meaning should be able
to point out anomaly any theory of
meaning should be able to tell why and
what kind of anomaly is prescribed in a
certain language for example why can't
rice a coffee I streams can take
dictation why is this an anomaly the
reason is any theory of meaning any
semantic rule should be able to point
out why is this not a legal sentence
coffee ice cream can conduct a dictation
right so basically because it doesn't
make meaning because coffee ice creams
are not human says okay not
dictation in the very idea of dictation
is that it is something which which is
moving which can hear a conversation and
these cannot take any motion so this is
an anomaly similarly self-contradiction
any theory of meaning any semantic rule
should also be able to point out
self-contradiction in sentences for
example when I say my dog is not an
animal why it is self-contradictory
because it is an animal right when I say
it is my my dog is so and so people try
to give them name this is basically self
contradictory because most dogs are
animal and so you cannot create them or
say that this is not an animal
also things like ambiguity why isn't it
clear when where one intends to go when
I say I need to go to the bank so same
theories of meaning should also be able
to point out this kind of problem this
kind of ambiguity when I say I'm going
to the bank it's not very clear when I
am going on to the unless the context is
in before it or after it for example I
am trying to tell you what a situation
or about my visit to some to to some
water body or some ocean or some nice
place and then I'm trying to say that I
am going to the bank then it has some
meaning so basically then any theory of
meaning should be able to explain these
kind of ambiguities also cinah limit is
and any theory of meaning should also be
able to explain why is anonymity or
house anonymity exist for example when I
say the rabbit is not an old enough how
does it mean the same as rabbit is too
young when I say not old enough how does
it mean or what does it mean or what is
how is it translated to the fact that it
is too young so any theory of meaning
should be able to also comprehend that
or should also be able to explain how
does this happen and the last is called
the end
tailmon which is when I say that that is
my uncle how does it automatically
generate this fact that pat is a male
because uncle is a male and so pat is a
male that kind of rule so any theory of
meaning should be able to do that now
when listeners they figure out meaning
of a sentence they need to pay attention
to more than just the meaning of
individual words if you don't do that
what will happen is the meaning would
change
so although the sentence would have the
same semantics you will have the correct
format but meanings would change and
if you look into these two sentences the
profits are failed the student then the
student failed the professor they have
entirely too different meaning into it
and so any theory of meaning should be
able to explain why this happened
because when I say the professor failed
the student it is basically failing in
an exam but when I say the student
failed the professor is basically not
failing the professor in an exam but
basically because that's not possible
and that's the theory of meaning it says
that this is not possible so the
students don't take an examine so this
is the how the world runs and so when
the student failed the exam it is
basically failing him in terms of
certain values in terms of certain facts
certain trust that the professor had so
he failed the student failed the
professor in terms of trust whereas when
the professor failed the student he
failed in terms of and academic value or
an academic exam now the study of
semantics also involves the study of
truth condition so for any sentence to
be truth when I'm doing a sentence when
I am looking at a sentence the the
theory of or the study of semantics or
the means study of semantics rules
should also be able to point out whether
a sentence is true or not because truth
conditions often decide whether a
sentence exists or of what is the
meaning of a sentence and the
relationship between different sentences
that it has so truth conditions are
simply circumstances that make something
true for example the dog chasing the cat
is a two-sentence but the cat chase the
dog is not in terms of truth conditions
is not valid because cats don't chase
dog in normal meaning and so any idea of
meaning or any sentence or semantics or
any sentence which has sentences like
the cat chase the dog in entirely wrong
although this kind of meaning can
generate in an animation movie but
normally seeing the dog will only chase
the cat and so this is the truth
condition hence our understanding of
meaning of our sentences requires some
steps the and RR phase or how we
understand meaningful sentences they are
bound by certain variables certain
factors and understanding of the meaning
of each word or sentence so how you make
meaning from a sentence or how you make
meaning from a word a comprehension or
text passage is basically by
understanding the meaning of each word
that it has
remember the professor Felder stood in
this room when the professor so looking
at the word looking at meaning from each
word you can then say that profits are
failing the student is an exam in an
exam but student feeling the professor
is in terms of trust so there it is
academic there it is trust so our
understanding of meaning it relies on
understanding the meaning of each word
understanding the syntax of the sentence
so whether the syntax is correct or not
whether the grammatical rule is correct
or not and understanding the truth
conditions so how do we generate meaning
we and generate meaning by understanding
each word from or understanding the
meaning of each word a sentence has next
thing that we do is we look at the
syntax and we understand the syntax if
the syntax is wrong then the meaning
will not be generated out of it because
the sentence will not be correct and the
third thing is we also look at whether
in terms of the world view whether the
sentence is true or not so the dog chase
the cat chase the dog each word has a
meaning the dog has a meaning the cat
has a meaning the chase has a meaning
also the syntax is correct because there
is a subject verb and object but in
terms of truth conditions the fact that
normally seeing the cats cannot chase
dogs or do not chase dogs that basically
established the fact that it is in terms
of truth conditions it is false no we
looked at semantics which is the meaning
of a sentence the next thing that we are
going to look at is pragmatics which is
basically the social rules of how
language should be spoken or what are
the ethic Cates and kind of
conversations which are out there so
basically in pragmatics we we look at
the sentences what is the way what is
the social way of conversing what is the
require adequate switch chef so
basically for example good pragmatics is
saying conversational greetings like
saying hi how are you somebody says you
have to reply to him in a certain way so
if somebody say hi how are you and you
say something which is very rude that's
not a good pragmatics so pragmatics are
certain rules of language or certain
rules of conversation so although your
sentence would make meaning but how they
should be converts all people should be
conversing with the sentences that
you're making is what is the study of
pragmatics so suddenly 1979 he points
out then in listening to another person
we must understand the kinds of
that they demand in different responses
to us so ha Saturday says that there are
certain sentences are the sentences
which have been uttered which are
uttered by people and all these
sentences have different kind of
responses and we should as a listener
not only be able to understand the kind
of sentence that a person is speaking we
should also be able to give a reply
befitting the kind of sentence which has
been asked for example one of the ways
or one of the particular ways of
communication is called the assertive
sentence in a certain sentence the
speaker his or her he asserts his belief
for example was like it's hot in here
I am a Gemini it doesn't require any
kind of response so if somebody is just
asserting something or saying something
now there are directives which people go
ahead and speak and these directories
are instruction and so you should be
replying in similar to it for example
the speaker saying to a listener saying
close the door or don't trust him when I
say close the door
it requires an action from the listener
and so that is the kind of thing you
choose and so you do not need to speak
anything when somebody says close the
door you close the door and as I don't
trust him you don't say anything to it
you basically have to listen to it and
act upon it then there is something
called calm uses these are utterances
that commit the speaker to some later
action for example I promise to be good
now it basically says that the speaker
is promising or it's basically he's
telling the the listener that in future
he is going to do something for example
being good or somebody says I will be a
wing man which means that this person is
going to help the other person and so
this requires certain other kind of
responses then the directives in an
expressive described psychological stage
for example in an expressive you don't
really know what to do so you have to
read to it example I say that I thank
you for the favour you did to me this is
an expression sentence this is a
expression of thanks now I don't know
what you could be doing with it but this
is an expressive or example if I say
thank you for nothing this is an a
psychological state of the speaker and
so you should be responding in a similar
way as against a directive or a commerce
sentence and the lastest declarations
are speech acts in which the utterances
itself are the actions now in this cases
the sentences which are speak spoken are
itself certain actions for example I now
pronounce you husband and wife
this basically says that there are
certain action into it the act itself
the fact itself that my pronouncing
makes you husband and wife is true or
sentences like you are so dead
are basically and are trends it's a
declaration and the sentence itself
declare a particular fact on to it and
so people should be hanging around to it
now according to sadly speech act theory
part of a job of listener is to figure
out which of the five particular
utterances are there and to respond
heartily so basically it's not only
understanding the meaning the structure
of a sentence and so on and so forth
it's basically a we go a level ahead of
it and then we also look at how people
talk to each other and how do they
generate sentences for example best
example of pragmatics like look at the
two figures so in the first case
Sherlock saw the man using binoculars
which means that he used the binoculars
for seeing the man and in the other case
Sherlock showed the man using the minor
colours in the second case he saw the
man who was using a by Nicholas and so
this is the difference between
pragmatics or this is the difference
between house and consensus so both are
the same sentence same legal constraints
same structure same meaning but the
pragmatics of to it or that's not what I
meant when I asked you to carve it so
what he has done is he has carved
something out of it and so the subject
meaning so basically the idea of how a
sentence should be really constructed so
in this class in this particular lecture
what I tried to do is I try to show to
you what is language what is the meaning
of language what are the different
constraints of a language and basically
then we went ahead and looked at each
constituent one by one and how do they
play their role into the language itself
or the working of the language itself
now in the upcoming section we look into
how speech is produced when a speech is
how people utter languages and what are
the confusions and problems in our turns
of these languages so in the first part
we looked at parts of
and how they're combined together to
form the language itself the second part
so it is in terms of rules and
structures and so on and so forth in the
last in the next part that we'll talk
we'll talk about errors in production of
speech or how speech is per use in
itself and several factors related to
that so let's meet the next stuff in
discuss this thank you
[Music]
you